(audience applauding)
- Well, one of the most
memorable scenes in the
"Never Been Kissed" film is
the iconic kiss at the
end, when Josie's waiting
for Sam to kiss her at the baseball field.
Talk about taking a risk and
putting yourself out there
right in public, something
we all know everything about.
Let's take a look.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat instrumental music)
(crowd cheering)
♪ Well it's been building
up inside of me ♪
♪ For oh I don't ♪
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- [Molly] So that's a movie.
- Oh gosh, I just wish that
Michael Vartan could be here
to like live out that moment again.
It was one of the best,
most fun moments of my life.
(upbeat instrumental music)
(audience cheering)
♪ Well, it's been
building up inside of me ♪
♪ For oh, I don't know how long ♪
- So sweet.
♪ And I don't know why
but I keep thinking ♪
♪ Somehow I ♪
(audience applauding)
- [Michael] Oh, absolutely.
- Oh, Michael.
- Oh, Drew.
- Oh, Mr. Coulson.
- Oh, Josie Grossie.
- Oh, God!
(audience calling out)
I am still Josie Grossie.
(audience applauding)
- I've gotta say,
I haven't seen that clip in
years, and standing there,
I got emotional.
You know?
- Me too!
(audience applauding)
- I mean, this movie's been
a huge part of my life.
Every time I'm stopped, it's always,
"Never been kissed, never been kissed."
(audience laughing)
So it's a pretty amazing
thing to be a part of.
And this reunion is just wonderful.
- Do you have any particular
memories from the movie?
- Yeah, there's a...
There's a story about the famous scene
that very few people know about,
and I'm not sure I should... (laughing)
- [Drew] Do I know about it?
- No, you do not know about it.
- Oh my God!
(audience cheering)
All right, even I get to get
a spoiler and an insight here.
I can't wait to hear what you have to say.
- So I get up to the mound.
We embrace, and we start kissing.
And you really kissed me.
I mean, you really kissed me.
(audience cheering)
I was not, I was not
ready for it in the least.
And I'm a man.
I was a very young man back then.
And just, you know, I had feelings, and-
(crowd cheering)
(crowd applauding)
And the feelings were
just, they just happened.
And I very quickly realized
I was in a very bad spot
because I was wearing very,
very loose sort of like slacks.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
And I thought, this is gonna
be a disaster when they cut.
I must preemptively end this.
So what I did is in a
panic, I just yelled, "Cut,"
and bent over and said,
"Oh guys, sorry, my back.
I put my back out playing ball."
- What?
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- And I started, you know,
remember me cutting the first
take, or one of the takes?
And anyway, I went off into my corner
and I was thinking horrible
thoughts, like, you know,
dead puppies, dead puppies.
- Oh my God!
(audience laughing)
- And so finally I was
able to compose myself,
and luckily the, you know,
subsequent scenes went on
without a hitch, but that was,
you're a very good kisser.
- [Drew] Well, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my God, seeing you!
- It was very embarrassing.
- Thank you.
And you know, you weren't
married at the time.
- Nope.
- So yeah, I went for it
because you were single.
And I felt like I wasn't
gonna offend anybody.
(audience applauding)
Also, a poll for women, and
maybe you men feel this way too,
you did something that for
me is the ultimate in romance
where the kiss, which is
when you put your hands
on a woman's face-
- [Audience] Oh!
- Sweet!
- It's like...
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
So, I, did you keep a little
memento from the film?
- Yes.
So I don't know if you'll remember,
but you gave me this very
sweet little wrap gift.
It was a beautiful little fern.
Well, I thought it was a
fern, so I kept it, of course.
And over the years,
this thing was growing.
At first, it was this very tiny
little stem with, you know,
a few leaves, and it
started growing and growing.
Of course, I named a Drew.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
And it's now...
No kidding, it's 15,
16 feet tall, and it's,
there it is.
- Oh wow!
- [Michael] There it is.
- Wow!
(audience applauding)
That is so sweet!
- That is sweet.
- This little thing, and
I've literally kept a picture
of Drew in my phone for
20 years in the odd chance
that I would run into you and say,
"Do you know what this is?"
- Oh!
- And I'll never-
- So sweet!
(audience applauding)
So sweet!
- That is really impressive.
And I think it's a perfect metaphor
for maybe this film does keep growing,
and it stays connected.
I mean, look at, we've
got totally Rufus sign.
We have you wearing the
Josie Grossie dress.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience applauding)
- You know, we love "Never Been Kissed,"
Drew, David, and you
know, Michael and Molly.
And we also, you know,
were at the precipice of
launching huge careers.
We had James Franco, Jessica
Alba, Octavia Spencer.
- Oh!
- John C. Reilly.
- Mm-hm.
- It was a real dream cast.
- Yeah.
- And it just was lightning in a bottle
and a moment we all cherish and we wanted
to share with you today.
And I want to thank you, Molly, my Anita.
Please be sure to catch
Molly in "The Other Two"
now streaming on HBO Max
with two episodes weekly.
And David, my Rob, our Rob.
And as they say in "Never Been Kissed,"
Mr. Coulson rocks my world!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat instrumental music)